If we define a human being as a being in steady search for meaning,...
...here is the very place where religion comes in.
Inasmuch as man or say, a large essential part of the human population,...
...is going one step beyond that,...
...inasmuch as they strive also for something one might call an ultimate meaning.
And in a religion, man, a religious individual, is not satisfied just with finding a meaning,...
...a meaningful task to complete.
But he goes or she goes a step forward...
...by also including the awareness of a task - giver, as it were.
This is divinity.
So, there is a new dimension they enter. Religious personalities enter...
...by striving for something they may experience...
...and be perceptive of, in terms of an ultimate meaning.
Not just meaning but an ultimate meaning.